you guys use food delivery services
because I use it amazing once a day at
least
III use GrubHub more than is like Rojo I
don't like I don't like postmates and
all that stuff I overeat is the best one
I don't like paying for delivery exactly
uber eats is the best one and you know
the best thing about we reach you get a
tracking so like you're like where's my
[ __ ] taco at you see on the map where
the driver is so you can see I'm driving
to you to the point of him coming to
your house and then you go in exactly to
walk outside listen I don't want nobody
drive my [ __ ] food and I want nobody
breathing on my father yeah they put in
there and grab some fries when they're
hungry yeah I gotcha muffled oh I like
kind of I don't like not like GrubHub is
on this [ __ ] you knew all young men you
could get if I wake up in the middle man
go get two tacos I'm more Park
so can you there's no reason and grub up
with all that [ __ ] huh well young man
dawg
I like this [ __ ] guy wouldn't leave
the goddamn house it was like depending
on him anyway that's all that [ __ ] I
would love to be living at the house and
gets all that HMO food sent to his ass
game is this guy gets an HMO food that
[ __ ] done hmm who she got sick on and
all that [ __ ] he would never get
delivery sushi okay I know what do you
get delivered I can't like pizza I get
she buy any good pieces little well I
like that place I'm like I like that
place on the corner can't like I had to
pick like one of the fast food ones it'd
probably be Pizza hugger downtown Papa
John really I just got last night
delivered a taste Chicago I'm gonna be
part of it is it's owned by the Joe
Mantegna we are something like [ __ ]
god--all it's horrible God also so God
that should be leaves flavor retro so
let me do my review of what I did last
night there they have a Chicago
deep-dish pizza now I grew up with Robin
love you I love that it I decided to pay
it with $29 for a charge yes so I'm like
it's worth it I'm just going to act like
this is like dinner like lasagna or
something I I get it delivered it was so
[ __ ] horrible it was like remember I
remember as a kid my mom would take like
flour and water and make like bread
that was really like it tastes like this
wit or started in there no I don't want
to go I would know it would be that was
the worst behind them to this part of
the [ __ ] I lived in Hollywood for god
knows how long and I moved up here when
I moved up here my wife and I would do a
little better when we were in Hollywood
she had gotten raised I was trying to
make a little money we had no mercy so
we would go out to dinner three nights a
week you know what I say dinner to one
it out no we were going to those medium
range joints you know just to see you
want to know with the firehouse pizza on
the corner of Magnolia that blows all
this stuff blows yeah even like my
little Tony
oh that's god-awful in it so we went to
taste the Chicago dog I don't know how
many conversations I've had with with
Lee about Chicago hot beef and how good
I like it and how they put the peppers
and the onions and you know when I like
what I even hear when I got an offer
from Chicago like I already have my menu
plan now like I know I'm gonna go here I
took Lee last time and one of JT Bravo's
[ __ ] best guy in the world picked us
up and took us to the best hot beef
place man I love listen there's
something about a hot beef sandwich so I
see Chicago it's Joe Montana I can't go
[ __ ] wrong right I can't go wrong I
go in there I think we dropped $60 dog
huh two hot beef sandwiches or something
else and it was like okay you know again
this is what it is this ain't [ __ ]
Chicago I'm saying so they fly the beef
they fly the bread dog me and my wife
took like two bites of everything and
got up and walked up yeah we got up and
walked out I heard this a great place in
Hollywood called baked wings baekeland
chicken wings of baked oh yeah yeah I
heard about that yeah I went to that I
did that show you did Hot 100's on every
I couldn't find your [ __ ] sing oh
yeah so I did a special edition of is
that where we went to this place
downtown and it has a hot Nashville
chicken yeah how is the normal spiciness
I tell you what man it was uh it was
some of the best-tasting chicken ever
and even though we we ate
it's called hallen raised and there's
like a three-hour wait all day before
they open those people lined up down the
door and it's delicious but we got the
hot extra hot and then a item where they
don't have on the menu and it was so
[ __ ] hot that Sean says hey
everything we just had there is hotter
than what we eat on the show hot ones
but if you want to look at it it's just
a detect on Sean Evans red band it's a
it's on there but did you [ __ ] for fire
and did you have I was taking my for
like 24 hours I was on went on the
toilet it's just [ __ ] in fire I had to
take off my shirt you know how sometimes
for some reason your body go take off
all your clothes now when you're on the
toilet why is that that's the weird that
happens do you have that I have that
sometimes when uh when I would get too
high when you go to a pub and dairymen
there's a [ __ ] delivery guy spits in
the rubbish but yeah I was I thought I
was dying like that was awful Sean said
that he went back and he was same thing
I did not really like the Nashville
trick well I just went to Nashville I
love the city of Nashville I got a place
it's a great pizza joint and I think I
went to the wrong place I did not like
it I don't like to I don't like black
and [ __ ] I don't like what every like
that yeah I like spice the flavor I
don't care if you make your food hot
that's the mama but it better be
flavorful if you're just making it hot
to be cool yeah that's I don't see any
there be a oh yeah that's like Spencer's
gift you're almost buying it for that
like it haha like let's try to eat a
bite hahaha you know you do is we got to
eat like a mild life because that's what
I want I just wanted to highlight so it
takes us chicken with spicy like Popeyes
Chicken
oh he's a [ __ ] Papa but I told you
Doug when I went Lego to Tennessee I go
to Lee's mother [ __ ] chicken oh my
god oh my god that old-school fried
chicken that's all I want I want
old-school fried chicken you know most
good fried chicken puerto ricans Porto
Ricans could [ __ ] Mexican rice
chicken oh my god
[ __ ] them grow up in the Bronx you could
smell it as you're driving down the
street like somebody's making good
[ __ ] chicken to them I tell you what I
do my broke-ass meal of the day is go to
the grocery store and get drumsticks and
usually can get like 12 drumsticks 24
drumsticks for like three dollars I
guess yeah
the pavilions by my oh you cook them
yourself yeah in my wipers yeah and we
like I definitely don't come in like oh
you got them on the grill you're good
that's and it's like three bucks yeah
not on a chicken's [ __ ] dirty I'm
yeah you know they've been beat up and
kicked oh yeah I heard you get a cage
once yeah you look for [ __ ] animals
I've been tortured
you know you got to bite the [ __ ]
breast that's missing a piece like
somebody's burger like [ __ ] Lee's
tongue it's got a little blazer on it
like Lee's talking [ __ ] nah but man when
you get good chicken and then marinated
you know anything that you could
marinate like what I was you I don't
like I can't eat all those gamey stuff
yeah I can't eat game these stuff like
lamb I don't like I don't like that I
don't like I hate it for that I'll bring
it to a place well it's not a place it's
my friend's parents this [ __ ]
would give you a piece of meat you know
that's the best meal I've a coffin
really that's lamb and you like lamb how
come I didn't taste it because they
would marinate it for three or four days
and cut it into chunks and put on
barbecue on kebabs oh [ __ ]
lamination is exploring I tell my wife
my wife's one of those that when I
married it's a piece of chicken with
pepper and salt on it that's not that's
not cooking that's not cooking you got
to figure this out and then we would sit
together look up recipes I didn't occur
and lemon a lot yeah no no today I made
a [ __ ] halibut with a we took a
little time reaction I was in jujitsu on
the way back she goes we want to do
without halibut but you don't want
something different today I go get a
little four put some lemon juice in this
and [ __ ] teriyaki and close it up in
a piece of butter
you should have tasted that song and
halibut when I got